eine forschungsgruppe hat mehrere
erdbeben in der region leipzig
untersucht und kommt zu einem
beunruhigenden ergebnis demnach könnte
es dort größere erdbeben geben die
zerstörungen anrichten könnten eben in
deutschland eigentlich verrückt aber
offenbar doch möglich klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
das sind keine guten nachrichten die da
vom deutschen geoforschungszentrum
kommen das forschungsteam hat zwei
erdbeben aus den jahren 2015 und 2017
näher untersucht und ist zu einem
beunruhigenden ergebnis gekommen
eigentlich ist diese region kaum
erdbebengefährdet doch 2015 und 17 gab
es dort jeweils ein erdbeben einmal mit
der stärke 2,8 2015 und noch stärker
2017 mit 3,2 auf der
momenten-magnituden-skala ab 5,0 wird es
gefährlich und die beben waren zudem in
einer entfernung von 50 kilometern noch
spürbar
aber was hat die erdbeben ausgelöst
eigentlich liegt deutschland mitten auf
der eurasischen platte erdbeben sind
hier kaum zu befürchten aber eben nur
kaum und deutlich weniger in der region
um alle gibt es eine geologische
ausnahmeerscheinung die hallische
marktplatz verwerfung das klingt jetzt
nach einem riss im kopfsteinpflaster ist
aber bedeutend mehr
dort haben sich vor mehreren millionen
jahren zwei gesteinsplatten um mehrere
hundert meter in der höhe
gegeneinander verschoben eigentlich geht
von dort keine erdbebengefahr mehr aus
doch die neuen erdbeben waisen genau auf
diese beiden gesteinsplatten hin
die auslöser für die erschütterung lagen
nämlich in 22 beziehungsweise 29
kilometern tiefe die forschungsgruppe
ist jetzt sehr besorgt dass solche
erdbeben die verwerfung wieder
reaktivieren könnten und von dort
größere erdbeben ausgelöst werden
könnten und auf solche ereignisse sei
man nicht gut vorbereitet so der leiter
der erdbeben der universität leipzig sie
warf funkel gegenüber focus generell ist
in deutschland nur mit wenigen schwachen
erdbeben zu rechnen doch trotzdem gibt
es immer mal wieder welche anfang der
90er jahre zb im rheinland wo zahlreiche
häuser beschädigt wurden
das atomkraftwerk mülheim kärlich musste
wieder abgeschaltet werden weil der
rheingraben zuseher erdbebengefährdet
ist die naheliegende eifel ist aus
geologischer sicht ein aktives
vulkangebiet und erst am vergangenen
wochenende gab es einen schwarm beben im
vogtland an der grenze zu tschechien
also ein beben das aus ganz vielen beben
besteht die in kurzer zeit auftreten und
das am selben ort
es erreichte eine stärke von 3,3 alles
in allem ist das risiko gering
aber mit der region leipzig halle ist
ein neues gefährdetes erdbebengebiet
dazu gekommen und dort kann eben
schlimmes passieren wenn er also nichts
zum thema erdbeben in deutschland und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp und den
anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er
kein video denn die abo box auf youtube
die ist ja ziemlich unvollständig dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
einfach hier draufklicken und am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um
social media abonnieren das geht hier
erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der social
media welt und nicht die genau glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken neuer kontinent
entsteht in afrika ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran